quiero aclarar que el punto de mostrar
estas debilidades del sistema bancario
de reserva fraccionaria no es para
argumentar que tenga que desaparecer o
bien que de cierta forma sea inviable de
hecho es súper viable es el sistema que
todas las economías de mercado o bueno
al menos todas las que conozco han usado
por muchos años y siguen usando la razón
con la cual lo estoy haciendo es para
mostrarte que no es el único tipo de
sistema y que realmente tenemos que ver
que otros sistemas que existen para
darnos cuenta que pues realmente no es
una ley de física si una ley natural que
tengamos que usar la reserva
fraccionaria en el vídeo pasado
comentábamos que para que la reserva
fraccionaria funcione pues tiene que
haber ingeniería financiera que tiene
algunas desventajas la primera es
inestabilidad que se combate con un
seguro bancario y pues también haciendo
que el banco central actúe como un
prestamista de último recurso la segunda
debilidad es un mal incentivo y no me
las estoy sacando de la manga y de hecho
están muy bien documentadas un mal
incentivo es pues no se desea por
ejemplo usualmente cuando inviertes tu
dinero en cualquier otro tipo de
institución financiera y pues esas
personas invierten su dinero en otro
lugar pues usualmente ellos te tienen
que convencer de que tan buenos son
invirtiendo dinero en el caso de los
bancos comerciales esto ya no sucede
como ya todos los bancos están
respaldados están asegurados por él y
para entonces los clientes se preocupan
por los cajeros por el servicio de banca
en línea y por otro lado los bancos ni
siquiera mencionan que están prestando
su dinero y menos aún intentan
convencerlos de que es de una manera
responsable otra cosa que también está
súper bien documentada es que con el
sistema bancario de reserva fraccionaria
hay un montón de la responsabilidad de
creación de dinero en manos de los
banqueros
esto se debe a lo que dijimos de que los
bancos crean dinero haciendo préstamos y
entonces se le quita la responsabilidad
al banco central ahora ya con esto
platicado la pregunta natural es si hay
otras alternativas ahorita no quiero
defender una ni otra sólo quiero ver que
esta de acá no es la única posible que
hay otra forma de hacer banca
de hecho la alternativa es la original
el sistema bancario de reserva completa
y seguro por el nombre puedes saber de
qué se trata justo es que el banco es
decir cuando alguien deposita su dinero
en el banco mete reservas en sus bóvedas
o en su cuenta de cheques entonces el
banco debe de mantenerlo siempre
entonces voy a dibujar un banco por aquí
entonces si tengo un banco y yo depósito
ahí sesenta pesos tres billetes de
veinte pesos del banco de méxico
la distancia 60 pesos y entonces si yo
dijera que pues no sé esto lo quiero
tener a la vista siempre en cualquier
momento y pues cuando yo quiera ir a
cajero y retirarlo entonces el banco
tendría que tener toda esta reserva en
sus bóvedas tú dices va pero entonces
como se hacen los préstamos para pues
para que haya préstamos el banco tendría
que decir mira la verdad no creo que
utilices tus 60 pesos entonces por qué
no hacemos lo siguiente depositas un
cachito un cachito digamos este billete
de 20 este de acá y el resto me lo
prestas así literalmente te lo estoy
pidiendo prestado esto de aquí no es un
sistema tan raro verdad o sea cuando
compras un cedé en un banco cuando
adquieres un cd
entonces esencialmente así funcionan las
cosas verdad están tomando prestado tu
dinero de una manera explícita no te
dicen que este dinero está a la vista no
va estar disponible de hecho va a estar
como encerrado mientras ellos lo prestan
verdad y entonces el banco no se lo
presta por un mes o seis meses lo que
sea mientras más te prestan más interés
te van a dar y al final del plazo te
regresan tu dinero entonces digamos que
esto de aquí lo quieres a la vista
la vista y luego esto de acá arriba lo
dejas para que se preste sería un
depósito a largo plazo a largo plazo
y luego pues el banco ya sabes podría
prestar este dinero podría prestar estas
reservas a algunos proyectos pero este
proceso de préstamo no va a crear más
dinero no va a aumentar la oferta de
dinero porque fíjate supongamos que se
lo prestamos a alguien y se le deposita
en su banco entonces deja lo pongo por
aquí hay que dar los billetes los
billetes de 20 pesos 40 pesos y puedes
decir a esto se parece muchísimo a la
reserva fraccionaria porque otra vez hay
cinco billetes en el sistema pero la
diferencia es que nadie puede utilizar
estos dos billetes estos 40 pesos para
pagar nada o sea no puedes escribir
cheques por ellos aunque si puedes
escribir cheques por esto de acá o sea
si puedes escribir un cheque digamos por
20 pesos y eso estaría bien porque está
respaldado por este billete que está en
el banco entonces como puedes ver no se
está creando dinero en realidad las
únicas reservas que sirven como dinero
que sirven para respaldar cheques son
los tres billetes originales este de
aquí y estos dos de acá ok lo que está
fácil es de este sistema bueno primero
hablemos un poco acerca de las
desventajas la principal desventaja es
que ahora el banco no va a poder ganar
intereses por el dinero que está
y muy probablemente va a tener que
cobrarle comisiones más altas a sus
clientes por qué pues porque lo están
guardando en la bóveda lo están
manteniendo seguro y también te lo están
manteniendo disponible verdad puedes
escribir cheques por él o bien puedes ir
al cajero automático te están ofreciendo
un servicio y en la actualidad es
distinto porque o bueno en el sistema
actual en la reserva fraccionaria todos
esos servicios este pues son mucho más
baratos incluso gratis si tienes
suficiente dinero porque es porque
guardan su dinero verdad y pues te lo
dan en el cajero puedes escribir cheques
te dan una tarjeta de crédito o de
débito todas esas cosas y larsson por la
cual el banco puede hacerlo gratis es
porque pues están prestando el resto de
tu dinero verdad una gran cantidad como
90% ganan interés y así es como ganan
dinero acá es mucho más explícito el
préstamo acá abajo esto está a la vista
es un servicio que te está haciendo el
banco a ti te lo está manteniendo
disponible desde los cajeros y acá
arriba le estás haciendo un servicio al
banco le estás prestando lo presta con
un interés un poco más alto y entonces
así gana dinero salival y entonces ahora
platicamos un poquito qué sucede cuando
el banco central imprime dinero aquí no
se crea tanto
adicional de hecho no se crean nada de
dinero adicional después hablemos un
poquito más de dinero pero es
esencialmente el banco central va a
tener que imprimir más billetes para
mantener fluyendo la economía porque
ahorita con el sistema de préstamos pues
ya no se puede crear dinero que se pueda
utilizar como moneda hay como te
comentaba de hecho este es el sistema
original se usó como hasta mediados del
siglo 14 cuando los banqueros venecianos
empezaron a pensar en las ideas de
reserva fraccionaria pues de hecho hubo
muchos bancos tradicionales que
estuvieron usando la reserva completa
como esta mediados del siglo 19 y
después más o menos cuando fue la gran
depresión digamos como los 1930 por ahí
muchos economistas serios economistas
muy importantes propusieron regresar a
la banca casi completa de reserva
completa ellos escribieron así muy bien
cómo sería paso a paso el proceso como
lo podríamos introducir sin que hubiera
ya sabes demasiadas interrupciones en la
economía claro un cambio a tan grande
escala siempre puede ser peligroso
verdad tiene algunos riesgos para la
economía y su estabilidad pero bueno si
quieres leer su propuesta y lo cual
realmente te recomiendo mucho porque
está bien emocionante
es entender pues muy a fondo cómo
funciona el sistema monetario si quieres
leerla te recomiendo que busques en
google un programa para la reforma
monetaria
la reforma reforma monetaria monetaria y
es un artículo de 1939 también puedes
ponerlo en google 1939 y de hecho
también puedes buscar en wikipedia desde
bueno en inglés y está en español no
estoy seguro pero puedes buscarla e
insisto cuando fue publicada un montón
de economistas apoyaron regresar al
sistema bancario de reserva completa